finnaly very rarely but occasionally
they'll have a point that I need to
consider and I will talk show host Randy
Rhoads Sunday at 8:00 Eastern and
Pacific on c-span's cue a listen to Q&A
on c-span radio on XM channel 132 and on
Sirius channel 139 it's also available
as a c-span podcast we're at the
National Press Club book and author
night with Don Ritchie whose new book is
called reporting from Washington the
history of the Washington press corps
mr. Ritchie how long did you work at
this book this book took me about 10
years it's actually the second book I've
written on the press car I wrote a book
before that called press gallery which
covered the nineteenth century and that
took about ten years so altogether I've
been working about 20 years on this
project how far do you go back to begin
your discussion of a history of the
press apart in this book I began in 1932
when Franklin Roosevelt and Radia really
changed the whole nature of the
reporting the previous book is about
newspaper reporters starting in 1932 you
had to deal with radio and then with
television and then with the internet
and the numbers began to increase
enormously so there are a few hundred
reporters in the 1930s there are now
thousands and thousands of reporters in
Washington DC right now how did radio
reporters how were they greeted when
they first came on the scene in those
early days they were not welcomed with
open arms the newspaper reporters really
didn't think the radio is a legitimate
form of reporting and the only way as a
radio reporter that you could get into
the Senate and House press gallery was
if you also were a daily newspaper
reporter otherwise you had to carry your
equipment around the halls and you
couldn't get into the press gallery it's
not till 1939 that a reporter finally
went to the Congress and said you know
we'd like to be able to cover the
Congress we can't do it if we can't get
into the press galleries and the
Congress created the separate radio in
the gallery at that stage 1939 became
the radio TV gallery
and what was the the subsequent addition
of television what was that transition
like television was a little easier
because the same networks that owned the
radio networks owned the first
television networks and for years there
were just three television networks and
they sort of ran the the shop of course
today we now have cable networks we have
a whole range of different types of
media networks that have come along and
of course everybody is now trying to
deal with the internet what does it
where does it fit is it the newspaper is
it a magazine is a radio broadcasting
television broadcasting well it's a
little bit of everything so where should
they internet reporters go in looking at
this history did you include the types
of writing and speaking that people did
and how that's changed over the years
yes I wrote about the columnist I wrote
about the wire service reporters who
were not allowed to express any opinion
or even any color at all I had to be
straightforward writing others were
expected to write in a more exposure
taurine nature and to really make draw
in the audience you are looking at
different styles of writing and what
also what would be accepted for them by
their editors and so I interviewed some
of the early reporters for USA Today
when their stories were literally only a
paragraph long and one of them said that
they were lobbying to create a pulitzer
prize for the best investigatory
paragraph but of course now even that
newspaper has much longer articles and
they've changed over time as as as any
form of media has changed did your
daytime job help you in your
investigations if it wasn't for my
daytime job I probably would not have
written this book but is there a Senate
history and I get telephone calls almost
every day from reporters who are working
on deadlines they need to know right
away they need to know when was the last
time this happened how often does it
happen would it be correct to say this
can I put this into context and it was
the curiosity I had from dealing with
them that led me to write these books
and so I'm not sure I would ever have
thought to write this if it hadn't been
for the
how long has there been ascended
historian this is a 30th anniversary the
Senate historical office was created in
September of 2005 and I came on board in
March of 2000 set in 1975 which is like
1975 and I came on board in 1976 so and
that was the creation of the Senate
historical office was in 1975 talk about
the picture on the cover of this book
yes it's a wonderful picture of John F
Kennedy surrounded by reporters out on
the White House lawn with the White
House behind them there in the Rose
Garden
it's an unusual angle because the White
House is looming up behind them John F
Kennedy instead of a central piece in
this book he comes about mid point in
the book but also he started out as a
reporter he was a reporter for the
Hearst Newspapers in 1945 in 1946 until
he decided that he didn't want to just
write about history wanted to make
history and he